ما مدى قلقك
بشأن مقتل ثلاثة جنود،
يبدو أن هذا كان أمرًا لا مفر منه أن هذا
سيحدث في
وقت ما حسنًا، ليس من المستغرب أن أه
قواتنا التي كانت في خط
النار الآن لسنوات عديدة في الشرق الأوسط
أه  تكبدت خسائر في الأرواح إنه أمر
محزن ووضعت واشنطن في
معضلة أه متى وكيف ترد
أم بشكل واضح الوضع في غزة
تأجج التوتر ولكن أه هذه الهجمات
كانت مستمرة حتى قبل الحرب في
غزة أه وكان الهدف بالطبع
أنه إذا  نحن نقاتل أه
الإرهابيين هناك نمنعهم
من أه التنظيم والهجوم في
أماكن أخرى لذلك أعتقد أن
الإدارة ستضبط
ردها حتى لا توسع الحرب ولكن
بالتأكيد سترد بطريقة
مصممة لجعل الواقع المعزز مقنعًا
الحجة القائلة بأن هذه الهجمات يجب أن تتوقف،
كما تعلمون، هناك من يمكن أن
أسميهم المتشددين في
الكونجرس والحزب الجمهوري الذين يقولون
إن الإدارة يجب أن تضرب بقوة
على إيران نفسها، هل تعتقد أن هذا
متناسب، هل تعتقد أن هذا هو
ما  ستفعل الإدارة وإذا
فعلت ذلك فسوف يؤدي ذلك حتماً إلى تصعيد
هذا الأمر بشكل جيد لاستخدام لغة عامية فهو أمر خارج
عن السيطرة أه هذا أه هجوم
تم تحفيزه من قبل السلطات في
إيران ربما من قبل
الحرس الثوري الإيراني ولكن الرد على
إيران أه يوحي بذلك  نريد توسيع
الحرب ولا يوجد أحد
جاد حقًا في الرغبة في توسيع الحرب،
ولهذا السبب أعتقد أن الكلمة الأساسية التي يجب
مراقبتها هنا هي
الرد المحسوب والمتناسب أه، سنضرب بالتأكيد
أهدافًا في سوريا
حيث يوجد الحرس الثوري الإيراني  لقد تحصن الحرس الثوري الإيراني
حيث
أطلق مرتكبو هذا الهجوم
الطائرة بدون طيار لكن أه لا أعتقد أن هناك
فرصة على الإطلاق أن ننقل هذه الحرب
إلى إيران أه مثير للاهتمام، أنت تقول
من سوريا لأن الولايات المتحدة تقول إنها لا
تزال تحاول  لمعرفة ما إذا
كان من العراق من سوريا ولكني أعرف ما
تعنيه أن هذا هو المكان الذي يتمركز فيه أه
التحالف إذا أردت وكلاء إيران الخلفيين
أريد أن أسألك
سؤالاً آخر حول هذا فيما يتعلق
بالحث على الذهاب إلى الحرب ضد إيران
في حد ذاته، قال الاستراتيجي الديمقراطي سايمون
روزنبرغ بشكل أساسي عن الحزب الجمهوري:
إذا كنت غير راضٍ عن إيران اليوم، فإن أول
شيء يجب عليك فعله هو الخروج
لتمويل أوكرانيا بالكامل، فلا شيء
سيشجع إيران أكثر من
النصر الروسي في أوروبا، هل توافق
على
ذلك جيدًا؟  أعتقد أنه على اليمين على
مارك أم، كما تعلم أن هناك
أه توازن قوى عالمي أكبر
يتم اختباره الآن، وقد ألقت إيران
كل ثقلها أه بعضًا من
تقنياتها، والقدرة على صنع الطائرات بدون طيار أه،
وراء هجمات روسيا أه في أوكرانيا،
وبالتالي  هناك حاجة ملحة في
واشنطن لضمان استمرارنا في
دعم أوكرانيا وهذا يجعل
مشكلة سياسية صعبة للغاية هنا
لأن الجمهوريين ربطوا التمويل
لأوكرانيا وإسرائيل
باتفاق الحدود الذي يتم التفاوض عليه، لذا فهو
تقاطع معقد للغاية بين الأجانب وإسرائيل.
السياسة الداخلية ولكني أعتقد أن روزنبرغ
محق تمامًا في أن أه آخر شيء
نريده هو الانسحاب من أوكرانيا
أه أو أه الابتعاد عن
الشرق الأوسط والسماح لكل من روسيا وإيران
بتحقيق النجاح أه دعني أتحول
الآن  فيما يتعلق بالحرب التي شنتها إسرائيل على غزة ضد
حماس، فإن الادعاءات
والمعلومات الاستخباراتية التي يبدو أن إسرائيل قد
شاركتها تظهر أن 12 12 عضوًا من
وكالة الأمم المتحدة للإغاثة والأعمال الإنسانية التي
تتعامل على وجه التحديد مع اللاجئين الفلسطينيين
التاريخيين
قد اتُهموا بمشاركة 12
من أعضائها في أكتوبر  السابع
الآن تقول الأمم المتحدة إن هذه
مزاعم خطيرة للغاية وأعتقد أنهم
طردوا هؤلاء الـ 12
والتحقيقات مستمرة، دعني أسألك
أولاً هل يجب على الولايات المتحدة
ومجتمع المانحين تعليق التمويل مما
يؤثر على المساعدات في هذا الأمر  beled
Enclave
الآن حسنًا، آمل أن يكون تعليق
التمويل من قبل الولايات المتحدة وثماني أو تسع
دول أخرى إجراءً مؤقتًا أه
يهدف إلى الضغط على إدارة الأمم المتحدة
لاتخاذ بعض
الخطوات الجادة لإصلاح الخلل إذا
استمر تعليق التمويل أه لمدة  لفترة طويلة جدًا،
سيكون له تأثير خطير للغاية على
الوضع الإنساني على الأرض،
وحتى إسرائيل تعترف بأن أونرا هي
أفضل وكالة تابعة للأمم المتحدة في وضع يمكنها من تقديم
تلك المساعدات الإنسانية، لذلك
نحن نمارس القليل من
تكتيك الضغط هنا  لجعل الأمم المتحدة تستيقظ على
ما يعرفه الجميع بصراحة على أنه
مشكلة طويلة الأمد حيث أدخلت حماس أه
عددًا لا بأس به من مناصريها
وأنصارها في بيروقراطية الأمم المتحدة
والآن نجد أن بعضهم
انخرط بالفعل في 7 أكتوبر  أه
مذبحة إذن أه مرة أخرى أتمنى أن تكون
نقطة ضغط أه أه قصيرة المدى وأن
تتحرك الأمم المتحدة بسرعة أه تحاول التعامل
معها حتى يمكن استئناف التمويل